alright I have the most epic one more  thing ever despite what Brian is going  to tell you because as you know I have  some favorite things in the world one of  them is George W Bush the other one  Dierks Bentley last night they met in I  think it was in Missouri they run event  that's Luke Bryan who kind of got cut  out of the picture but we don't really  care as much about him I mean I like him  and all but so this is like one of my  worlds collided and Dirk said that he  told the president that I'm his biggest  fan and the president said well he's my  biggest fan so I almost fainted and in  five fan photoshop's but all my  favourite guys together there's Peter  and Jasper with his paw River my  shoulder I'm not in them your next year  that's a great shot awesome that's one  more thing ever I'm done